hello and welcome everyone thank you for
joining us for today's webinar
utilizing the lens epithelial explant
culture system to investigate cataract
formation presented by Daisy shoe PhD
student the University of Sydney
Australia I'm Christie Jeolla blabbers
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
herbs and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific to learn more about our
sponsors please visit thermo Fisher comm
forward slash cell culture heroes
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box type in your question and
click send will answer as many of your
questions is we have time for at the end
of the presentation additionally if you
are viewing this webinar on-demand you
may continue to submit your questions
when they will be answered via email
through the contact information you
provided at the time of registration
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please use the
ask a question box to is let us know
you're experiencing a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top of your
screen and follow the process to obtain
your credits our speaker today is Daisy
shoe for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen now without
further ado please join me in welcoming
Miss Daisy shoe
Daisy you may now begin your
presentation
Hey hi everyone thank you so much to
Christy and Chelsey and get Co cell
culture heroes for giving me this
opportunity to share my research with
you all and in particular share really
novel explant culture system that we use
in our lab so that's the purpose of my
talk today is really to highlight how we
create these lens epithelial excellent
cultures to study how cataract forms
um so a bit of background about me and
you can read more about it in the link
in the fire but I am actually an
optometrist by training and I work
there's a clinical optometrist for 2
years before I started my PhD and I am
currently working on my PhD revisions so
soon enough I will have that future
which is really exciting but I have
already started work as a postdoc in
Boston escaping by research institute
and it's quite a different sort of
project in itself like I'm looking at
retina now but I know a lot about the
lens having dedicated for years to it so
that's what I'll be talking about today
so firstly I'd like to really highlight
the anatomy of the eye and that's
something that we kind of probably don't
know much about and I honestly had to
learn all these different structures
it's a very complex organ there's at the
front of the I've got the cornea which
is like a transparent tissue at the
front at the back of the eyes got the
retina and that's really important for
getting all the signals in our world to
be converted to electrical signals for
the brain to interpret and inside the
eye towards the front part of the eye as
you can see there is a really beautiful
structure called the ledge and that is
that is actually really important for
focusing images from our world onto the
retina so if we didn't have a lens and
the retina still worked we still
wouldn't be able to see because we
really need the light rays to be focused
on to the retina and so you can see here
in the zoomed up version of the lens
that the lens actually is quite a
complicated structure there are there
are different cells and they arranged in
a really really organized way there's
the lens epithelial cells that's at the
front of the lens and you can see that
they have this cuboidal structure
they're like little bricks if you will
that they form a monolayer of cells at
the front of the lens then we have lens
fiber cells and they are actually
differentiated forms of lens epithelial
cells and these ones fiber cells are
really elongated and they form this
curved shape as you can see and actually
the highly ordered architecture of the
these lens fiber cells that's what
allows the lens to be able to focus
light onto the retina and also maintain
the transparency of the lens which is
super important as you can imagine if
you don't have a transparent lens and
you wouldn't be able to focus light on
of retina and now that's all encased
within the basement membrane which is
known as the lens capsule and that goes
all around the whole lens at the front
and the back all around and that
encapsulates the lens and that's really
interesting because the lens is actually
all the cells within the West never gets
exposed to any other cell in the rest of
the body so it's like its own thing
inside the eye and in fact if you were
to put a hole in the lens capsule and
all of a sudden the other ocular tissues
got exposed to lens epithelial the lens
five years old all those proteins inside
the lens they would probably not react
very well to that because that
environment is very contained within the
lens capsule and that's actually really
important to to know about the lens
because it keeps growing and growing
within that lens capsule and it never
sees anything outside of the ledge
okay so now my research is all about
epithelial cells as you notice there
were at the failure cells at the front
surface of the lens now what can happen
to these cells as I described they were
kind of like bricks or cuboidal shaped
cells what can happen is that they can
actually undergo transformations into
these cells called knees and calm
ourselves now that's a completely
different cell type you're going from
cuboidal square shaped brick-like cells
into the spindle shaped cells that
amazing kimmel and what happens during
that process is that the cells as I
described it's bricks they're like the
epithelial cells they have these really
tight adhesion to each other and they're
all so tightly adhered to the basement
membrane which I've described as a lens
capsule that's known as one lens capsule
so they are really solid in where they
are but when they differentiate into
these and criminal cells they transform
into these really irregular
strange-looking cells that are spindle
shaped that you long gated they've lost
their cells facilitation so they're no
longer stuck to each other and they've
lost us their cell to basement membrane
adhesions as well so they're no longer
stuck to the lens capsule and they also
start to secrete what is called
extracellular matrix which is it's what
the basement membrane is made of as well
but it's basically like a scar tissue to
be honest it's it's spindle shaped cells
mixed with this extracellular matrix so
this process is doing as EMT epithelial
to mesenchymal transition and a really
important growth factor that is known to
induce this EMT process is called
transforming growth factor beta and you
may have heard about this in a lot of
cancer research because it is a really
hot topic right now tgf-beta induced EMT
is actually a really prominent cause of
why cancer spreads to different parts of
the body so there's three types of EMT
there's
one which is embryogenesis so that's
when we're kind of in the womb and we're
developing into the complex human beings
that we become eventually but basically
if you can imagine we start out as a
single cells so that's that needs to
actually become all the different types
of cells that we are today so in order
to do that it needs to actually it needs
to actually undergo this EMT process so
that's actually a good type of EMT where
we're becoming more complex organisms by
having an epithelial cell
differentiating to these and climb
ourselves so that's good but there's
also type three EMT which I described as
metastasis which means the spreading of
cancer and what happens there is that so
say you have an epithelial type of tumor
so for example like a epithelial with
other breast cancer and that cancer
wants to spread to a different part of
the body well in order for it to move to
a different part of the body it has to
undergo EMT it has to break away from
the basement membrane break away from
all the cells that they're attached to
and actually migrate to a different part
of the body and maybe some kernel cells
are cells at10 migrate whereas
epithelial cell just stay put so that's
why EMT is so important when cancer
wants to spread to a different part of
the body so that breast cancer could
potentially be a brain tumor for example
and it needs to undergo that EMT process
now my research is looking at fibrosis
which is the fancy way of saying
scarring so when you think about it like
if you if you cut your hand and you get
a really deep wound then your skin can
scar and that could be like a permanent
thing and the scar tissue as you see
it's often quite shiny and that's that
extracellular matrix I was talking about
that's actually really important for
closing up the room so obviously you
made a big cut and so the cells will
start to transform into these memes and
Komal cells because they want to close
up the room so they need to migrate to
the wound site and kind of
trapped and that contraction process
allows the wind to click to seal up but
then in addition to that the cells will
secrete that extracellular matrix and
that's kind of like padding if you will
if it's basically like kind of like a
little bit of a band-aid situation and
that shiny stuff is there to really heal
out that that spot that's open and
basically close it up so the skin is
protected so that's in the context of
the skin now I'm going to talk about
that now in the context of the lens and
I this is a paper that I published so if
you're interested in learning about more
about tgf-beta induced EMT in the eye
this is a really great paper to look at
because I pretty much talked about how
PDF Reader and juice DMT isn't actually
just relevant to the lens which is the
topic of this talk today but it's
actually important for all different
types of ocular tissues as I described
it's important in the cornea it's also
important in glaucoma which is another
eye disease it's important for the
retina and that's actually currently
kind of what I'm researching now in my
postdoc so if you're interested in that
topic do check that paper up
so back to the eye and the lens so I
pretty much described the lens
epithelial cells now what happens is
they can transform into these spindle
shaped mesenchymal cells and as I
described instead of having these really
perfectly cuboidal cells we have this
mass of amazing hyman cells and I've
depicted that as a red circle but
basically that's kind of that's
basically a cataract so if you think
about it if we have a scab on like a
scar in our skin that is not too bad
it's maybe cosmetically not that
attractive but it's not too bad for the
function of the skin you go ahead if
it's on your hand like it's still going
to pretty much work but if you have a
scab in your eye in particular in your
lens that's not a good thing because you
won't be able to see any more because
the purpose of a lens
is to maintain that transparency so that
it can then slide to be focused on to
the retina and if light can't even get
through the lens and you won't be able
to see and so that's why when it comes
to scarring in the lens research into
that is really important because we
really want to figure out how we can
maintain that transparency and one such
cataract that is caused by EMT is called
an anterior sub capsular cataract and
that's the basis for a lot of the work
that you do this is a picture of a
patient with an anterior sub capsular
cataract you can see that it's pretty
much localized in the a panel you can
see that it's dead in the center of the
eye and that plaque so when light hits
obviously it's going to hit in the
middle of the eye and the cataract is
right there so it's that's not a good
thing and the picture in panel B is
basically showing how light is hitting
it and it's getting all scattered and
that's what happens when people have
these types of cataracts is that light
just hits the speak the eye but it
doesn't translate into any sort of
useful visual image
so another type of cataract is an
interesting one it also is involved in
the EMT process is something that
happens after cataract surgery so the
good thing about cataract is that there
is a treatment for it you can remove the
cataract but the problem with this
surgery is that there's complications as
with all surgeries something can go
wrong later down the track and this so
the surgeon will basically remove the
Bass's lens fiber cells and they'll only
remove a circular portion of the front
part of the lens so you can see there
are some cells left behind they will
implant an intraocular lens into that
and that provides the the focusing
ability so it replaces the function of
the lens so that light can still be
focused on to the retina but what
happens is the residual lens epithelial
cells that are left behind at the
equator and as hard as the surgeon wants
to try to remove all the lens epithelial
cells it's impossible there's always
some selfless left behind and what
happens to these cells is they undergo
the EMT process and they start to
migrate and form this cataract onto the
back of the lens and you can see an
example of that that's basically all
these little cells that have formed a
secondary cataract on the back of the
lens and sometimes also on the implant
and that requires a secondary laser
procedure to remove so research into ent
and the lens is really trying to tackle
these two types of cataracts posterior
capsular opacification and anterior sub
capsular cataract so we're trying to
figure out how these forms and by doing
that we can pretty much find a novel
drug to block these processes
so the way in which our lab looks at
these processes is using a culture
system that is a primary culture system
and it's called the rat lens epithelial
explant system and what we do is we take
we take 21 day old whisker rats and we
isolate their eyes we take their lenses
we tear open the posterior capsule so
the back of the lens so we don't tear at
the front because that's where all the
precious anterior the precious lens
epithelial cells are so we tear that
open and what we do from there is we pin
down the this mono layer of cells onto a
35 millimeter culture dish and you can
see basically an example of that we've
got 2x plants pinned down on a
35-millimeter culture dish and I've now
got some videos that I'd like to show
you and they basically depict what it's
like when I'm at the dissecting
microscope it is a bit of a challenge to
really kind of like figure out how to
move your hands while you're looking
through a really magnified view through
the microscope so this technique
actually took me I think like probably
like six months to really get a handle
of so it does take a bit of time to
really perfect the formation of these
experts but once you get it done it's
really exciting and the lenses I've got
a video in there as well of lenses and
they're really really pretty they're
like they're transparent um little gems
I would like they're really pretty so
we'll play the video now so you can see
what it's like
and this is a microscope that I use and
you can see that I've already got some
lenses that I've prepared and they look
really cool they're really cute lenses
but okay great I hope you enjoyed that
video they're going to move on to just
showing you a paper that if you if you
want to learn more about creating lens
epithelial excellent systems obviously
is a really great paper and my
supervisor Frank Levesque you
contributed to this and it's just a
really great way to summarize exactly
how these exploits are created and how
they can be useful
alright so back to this diagram now what
we can do with these exponents is we can
add different growth factors into the
pink media as you can see the cells are
pinned down in and we put this pink
Culture Media insert into it and from
there we can basically add different
growth factors or inhibitors of these
growth factors and observe how these
ones epithelial cells change over time
so we've got TGF theta now and as I
described tgf-beta is a really important
and very potent inducer of EMT and these
pictures will demonstrate that so in the
control state so if we zoom in on these
little tiny circle X plants here if we
zoom in on that with a phase contrast
microscope you can see that the cells
form a really beautiful monolayers cells
they're like really organized they what
they are what we described is a
cobblestone like arrangement so the very
nice sheet of cells and just below that
image is a confocal microscopy image
labeling for alpha smooth muscle actin
an alpha smooth muscle actin is actually
a protein that is up regulated when he
has EMT so if the cells become these in
caramel they will they will start to
express alpha smooth muscle actin and
that's really important for the contract
self ability of the cell so alpha smooth
muscle actin is actually also found in
the heart so you can you can see some
similarities there there's a lot of
contraction going on when the heart's
pumping blood and surprisingly these
contractile cells get up regulated in
the eye in the lens in fact so so that's
what I'm going to show you now so we've
got a tgf-beta added to these explains
and you can see that they're no longer
cuboidal and organized they're starting
to elongate into these spindle shaped
cells and our four SMA that gets really
significantly up regulated and you the
really interesting thing is that our
fresh meat gets incorporated into these
stress fibers so you can see that
there's lots of lines about four SMA and
that's really important for its
contractile properties
so the the thing is with my research
it's all about how tgf-beta does this
EMT process and what's really
interesting is that tgf-beta isn't the
only growth factor that is in the eye
there's actually lots of different
growth factors that float around in the
eye and these are just a few of them
that are found in the eye and so my PhD
project is really trying to figure out
how these different growth factors
interact with tgf-beta because in the in
vivo situation so in in the actual in
our actual eyes we're not just really
studying teaching a feeder in isolation
there's actually lots of interactions
there so that was my question how are
the different growth factors impact on
tgf-beta so today I'm going to start
with EGF and then I'll move on to be and
PE later so the interesting thing is
that some what I found is that the
growth factors that fluid around in the
in the aqueous humor which is basically
the liquid inside our eye that they
actually do different things to teach a
feeder so firstly EGF which is epidermal
growth factor it appears to augment the
effects of tgf-beta so these are the
images ratios I showed previously and so
you can see now that if we add EGF to
the mix you can see that our form a is
getting up regulated but you can see in
the face contrast that more of the cells
are looking elongated so we've got we've
got instead of just a few cells
elongating into these nice and camel
cells got lots more and that was really
intriguing so the question really was
how's it doing that and so then I looked
at a so this is just to confirm we will
sit alpha smooth muscle actin and you
can see that it goes with TGA feeder
this is a Western blot and a Western
blot just looks at total protein and
looks at whether or not it's there or
not there
whereas the immunofluorescence it's
really useful because if it's there you
can see what kind of pattern it takes on
and as I described our first May dog
take on that stress by the light pattern
but with a western bolt we can really
quantify things so that's why it's so
useful to do a Western blot as well
because I'm going to get some statistics
on whether or not this is a significant
difference or not so you can see if we
don't have any growth factors no EGF no
TGIF feed are there's pretty much no our
source mate so that's the control state
now if we add TGA feeder you can see our
first mate goes up and that's what we
saw in the amino fluorescence but we add
EGF and tgf-beta then we could see even
more alpha smooth muscle actin interpret
mice and just below that is another kind
of contractile protein and that also
showed a similar trend so really this is
what this is telling us is that EGF
epidermal growth factor is somehow
making the effects exacerbating the
effects of tgf-beta so we're essentially
seeing a more exaggerated cataract form
so the question really was how is it
doing this and so that brings me to
signaling pathways and that's the pretty
much gist of what I do I look at
signaling pathways inside the cell so as
you can imagine the cells are kind of
contained within this membrane so if
something's outside of the membrane
how is it going to communicate a signal
to the inside of the cell for the cell
can do something about that signal and
so obviously those growth factors like
tgf-beta outside the cell how does it
actually impact on the cell the end well
the really cool thing is these cells
have these things called receptors that
are stuck onto the membrane and tgf-beta
can bind to its receptor which is the
tgf-beta receptor this types one and two
and from there it can activate that
receptor and then from that activation
of the receptor it can then activate
different signaling pathways inside the
cell so tgf-beta doesn't ever go inside
the cell it just activates a receptor at
the
at the membrane of the cell and then you
get all these crazy things happen so
eventually ending up in the cataract so
tgf-beta activates the smart signaling
pathway and that's a really funny name I
know when I first learned about this I
definitely thought smart sounded really
weird and in fact what it stands for is
small mothers against their kinds of
quick I think and so that's also even
stranger but the smart pathway is
actually the canonical pathway for
teacher feed also it gets activated and
in particular it activates much two and
three and when I talk about activation
I'm really talking about phosphorylation
so that's why there's a little P group
that's stuck there so and that's mad two
and three then forms a complex with
slide for that gets activated too and
the whole complex goes into the nucleus
and that can activate different genes to
be switched on or off in this case
they're activated EMT genes
now work in our laboratory also looks at
different signaling pathways that aren't
smart so if it's not mad
then it's called non-canonical so we've
got oak which is the extracellular
regulated kinase but basically that
that's a really important ask kinase
which is activated by tgf-beta work in
our lab has shown that tgf-beta can
indeed activate that and if you block a
signaling you can block the the EMT
process so it's very important also
tgf-beta to activate up now the question
was what about epidermal growth factor
receptor because because we found that
EGF which is epidermal growth factor can
open vent the effects of tgf-beta maybe
epidermal growth factor receptor
signaling somehow involved so that will
sort of I'll take on this and nobody had
looked at this before so we were like
okay we're not sure but there was some
studies in cancer research that shows
that tgf-beta could activate EGFR so
that kind of inspired it alright so what
we found was really exciting
we found that tgf-beta actually did
activate the phosphorylation of EGFR so
here we can see another Western blot
labeling for phosphorylated form of EGFR
and the gap th there that's always there
because that's a housekeeping protein
and so that enables us to know whether
or not we had equal loading of our
protein so we always compare all the
groups to gap th
so winter just pgf beetle at one minute
we don't see any phosphor EGFR but at 18
hours we see an operation of EGFR
signaling and that was really
interesting so T Jeffrey doe did indeed
activate EGFR but it was a delayed sort
of response where his EGF on the other
hand activated its own receptor
signaling very rapidly at one minute and
also at 18 hours so we can see here that
something's going on definitely the
tgf-beta dials activate EGFR but it
wasn't immediate and then we introduced
an inhibitor of EGFR signaling so this
will block EGFR signaling and you can
see here that if you add this into the
mix then TJ better can't activate EGFR
at 18 hours anymore
and the other interesting thing we did
was we looked at the gene expression of
EGFR using real-time PCR so you see in
the control state there's there's just a
basal level of EGFR but if you add
tgf-beta to the mix then there's a
significant upregulation of EGFR gene
expression so this is a really
interesting because as I was saying
tgf-beta is something that activates
occuring receptor and that's then
translated to all these things that
change in the cell but why is it
hijacking EGFR signaling because that
belongs to EGF if you think about it
it's something that EGF uses to activate
so receptor somehow tgf-beta was
activating EGF receptor signaling so
that was very strange um but really
interesting so the next question was
okay we know that tgf-beta activate EGFR
but is it even important in the EMT
process so these are the images I showed
earlier with the control and then we add
tgf-beta we got lots of our foursome a
which is that amazing caudal marker now
what happens if we add the inhibitor of
EGFR signaling with tgf-beta you can see
that we block our first mate so we no
longer see that EMT marker come off and
the inhibitor by itself just is another
control it doesn't induce EMT so you
don't see much our first mate getting
into those stress fibers there so we can
see here that tgf-beta requires EGFR
signaling in order to get the EMT so
it's actually really important to have
EGFR signaling so it's playing a big
role
so now we're back to this diagram again
where I show the tgop - sweets magic and
now I'm showing those does activate EGFR
and we did a whole series of western
blots to look at whether or not there
was some sort of cross talk between
smads in EGFR because we thought that
there probably was some sort of network
that formed between all these signaling
pathways they probably talk to each
other and just as some where is all that
I did indeed find that and I found that
there was some sort of cross talk and
feedback loop between EGFR and ugh
signaling so if you block up with you or
one to six you reduce EGFR signaling and
similarly if you block EGFR Sigma you
reduce up so there was pretty much
talking to each other so that was really
interesting and you can read more about
it in this paper here about comedian
EGFR signaling in TGIF either in juice
TNT there that will take you through all
the data which was quite complex okay so
the next question was okay so I'm
showing that there's some sort of
crosstalk between the non-canonical
pathways EGFR in urk what about does EGF
talk to smart signaling for example
which is the canonical signaling pathway
so what we decided to do was look at mad
nuclear translocation so as I told you
the smart to three proteins actually has
to transfer that forms of complex that
translates into the nucleus of the cell
in order to activate any sort of genes
so at two hours these are images taken
at two hours and these are
immunofluorescence images that label for
slide two three and you can see here
that in green this man 2 3 in the
control state is not in the nucleus and
the nucleus is these black like circles
here so they're not in the nucleus but
if you add TG afid are are two hours
thus mad goes into the nucleus and that
just shows that TJ Peters activating
smads and that's going to change the
genes and lead to EMT but what happens
if you have T
da da with the inhibitor of EGFR
signaling well nothing much happens it's
pretty much the same it looks the same
as tgf-beta the cells still have smart 2
3 in the nucleus so that was interesting
so we decided ok what about later at 18
hours
well we actually found that at 18 hours
while the controlling TG afina look the
same if you have the inhibitor we TGF
feed our then you don't see that
translocation occurring so this the
cytoplasm which is outside the nucleus
that now has the smart 2/3 so that was
really interesting so in order for
tgf-beta to activate smads and get back
into the nucleus you do need a GFR
ceiling because if you block that then
it's not going to happen
so definitely some crosstalk between the
canonical and non-canonical signaling
pathways so the next thing we decided to
do was look at whether or not tgf-beta
could up regulate other other EGF
ligands so I showed this earlier where
EGFR gets upgrade you later by tgf-beta
but you can see here with TI be tgf-beta
Crossley inhibitor which is pd 1 530
oh three five if we introduced that
inhibitor we reduce TGIF Eden's ability
to up regulate EGFR and the inhibit
itself as a control doesn't do anything
it looks like the control and now what
was really interesting is that heparin
binding like EGF like growth factor
which is part of the EGF family
perspectives and can activate EGF
receptor signaling it was really highly
up regulated by tgf-beta so that was
really interesting the tgf-beta somehow
increasing another growth factor in this
case HB GS and that could be blocked if
you had the inhibitor of EGFR signaling
and EGFR signaling to be inhibitor
itself didn't do anything so this really
is showing us that there's something
going on with TGIF PETA's up regulating
EGF like and so that was interesting
so that brings me on to the next slide
which is looking at these family of
genes which is known as The Addams
Family nazi the cootie kind but a
different kind they are disintegrating
and metallo pretty needs family so what
they do is they cut things they do what
is called extra domain shedding and they
basically cleaves EGF like s so that
they can become the active form so
sometimes when growth factors are
floating around because they can act so
potently on selves and actually cause a
lot of damage or good for the cell
sometimes they're not in their active
form so that's called the pro form and
they will just float around and not be
able to do anything until they're
pleased so they're cut in a way that
will activate them into the functionally
active form and so that's what happens
to the EGF ligands like HB gf they
actually need to be cleaved in order to
have the functional version floating
around to then activate the EGF receptor
so atoms do that and I thought this
would be a really great mechanism to tie
together the tgf-b or an EGF story so I
decided to look at all these different
atoms it's actually a lot of them and
you can see there's Adam 9 10 17 19 that
I looked at but the most prominent
result that I found was Adam 19 you can
see in the control state is there's not
much there and then that's really highly
up regulated with the addition of
tgf-beta and that gets suppressed all
the way down to basal levels when you
have the tgf-beta plus the inhibitor of
EGFR and EGFR inhibitor by itself
doesn't do anything so we can see here
that something's going on with Adam 19
tgf-beta is up regulating it so that
brings me to the next slide which is
really kind of putting it all together
so this is what I'm proposing that is
happening inside the cell so as we
showed tgf-beta activates its own
receptor that activates
the canonical smart signaling pathway
the ugh signaling pathway and now my
research was like okay EGFR involved
well the really telling thing was that T
jeffina didn't activate EGFR at one
minute but it was a delayed response so
that really suggests that maybe it
wasn't directly activating EGFR receptor
so the tgf-beta ligands when actually
going on to the EGFR receptor and
activating it but maybe it was some sort
of indirect response so what I what I'm
proposing is that possibly tgf-beta is
activating the smads and earth signaling
pathways and that thing goes on to
activate different genes one of which
was which is atom 19 and atom 19 then
gets made into a protein that can then
Cleaves the HB dia and release that
salutely soluble are functionally active
form of HB EGF that then binds onto EGFR
and then from there then there's that
crustal that happens between ik and EGFR
so possibly that is what's happening and
we really need to delve more into that
relationship to really figure it out but
that's that's kind of an exciting
finding from a research and you can read
more about this in a paper that I
published this year as I mentioned it
will it will detail all these especially
all the western blots there were many
many Western works ok so back to these
growth factors now what I mentioned
early is that there's lots of them and
another one is the BMP and the BMPs as I
described they different growth factors
can do different things to teach you a
freedom what I found was that BMP
actually played a different role
so BMP actually blocked tgf-beta in
juice PMT so here's the control state
with the phase contrast image you can
see cells a beautiful monolayer very
nice cobble stirring like arrangement
minimal alpha resume with expression
which is that amazing caramel marker we
add the tgf-beta so get you on gated and
then our first mate gets expressed very
strongly and also incorporated into
these um
see spindle-shaped cells in the form of
stress fibers now you add the BMP to the
mix and you block it so no longer as a
cells expressing our firm a and they're
also not getting cooperated in to stress
factors and you can see in the face
contrast that the cells are maintained
in these nice a sheet of epithelial
cells that aren't elongated so the the
next question of course was what sort of
dosage it was at a dose dependent
response and indeed we found that with
the control state our first may is
memories expressed in this question
blood and you add the TGIF feed our our
first mate goes up you add one nanogram
of B and P and you suppress it a little
bit but not not to the point of the
control state and you add higher doses
you can see that we suppress our first
mate pretty much down to basal levels so
definitely there was some sort of
relationship between the dose of B and
p7 and how effective it is are blocking
tgf-beta in to CMT
so now back to this signalling diagram
so as I described like we've got these
tgf-beta molecules they'll bind onto its
tgf-beta receptor but you've also got
this BMP and it binds onto the BMP
receptor so and that will activate the
receptor or phosphorylated now the
interesting thing about B and P and
tgf-beta is that they actually belong to
the same family so I'm I was very
surprised to find that they were having
very opposing effects because they're
all part of the tgf-beta super family of
growth factors and as such they actually
share some commonalities so they both
use smart signaling tgf-beta though uses
smarts 2 and 3 and B and P uses smudged
one 5 and 8 so a little bit different in
that sense
so what I found was that there was some
sort of differential activation of these
plant proteins so we can see here this
is a western blood and you can see that
tgf-beta we don't have any tgf-beta just
be in p7 is a first panel so I looked at
the time points 20 minutes 2 hours 4
hours and 6 hours you can see that if
you just have be in p7 alone it will
activate smads
1 & 5 and that's pretty strong all the
time points now if we just have TGIF
eater alone in the second panel we can
see that an OD mp7 we can see that tgf-b
to activate spots 2 & 3 very strongly at
20 minutes and two hours but what
happens if we combine the two well if we
combine the two you can see that now
tgf-beta tgf-beta induce smads to 3 so
this 1 to 3 that is the tgf-beta for
most III isn't up regulated and the BMP
version of this man's science 1 of 5 is
strongly up regulated so that was really
interesting so if we have the 2 growth
factors at the same time then BMP is
going to activate its own arm signaling
snaps parts 1 & 5 really strongly and
that actually suppresses the tgf-beta
smads
2 & 3 so there was some sort of rapid
thing happening at 20 minutes that was
causing this blocking effect of BMP
and we went to look at this further on
the gene level this is a real-time PCR
looking for looking at the ID 2 & 3
genes which are the inhibitors of
differentiation so those are the target
genes of being P 7 and you can see that
in the first tunnel of in the white box
here we can see that in the control
state there's like pretty high levels of
the IDs 2 and ID 3 as well if you add T
Jeffy's that suppresses ID 2 & 3 levels
so it looks like when teacher feet is
down regulating these genes but if you
have TGIF P 2 plus P & P then you can
restore ID 2 & 3 levels back to the
basal level so if anything it seems like
being p7 sort of protecting yourself
from TGS beaters suppression of ID 2 & 3
which appear to be important in making
sure that EMT is not occurring perhaps
on a basal level
so so that's the mechanism that we're
proposing so the interesting thing here
is that tgf-beta activates months two
and three
BMP activates much one five and eight
but they all share this common side sled
force so they're both needs made for to
form that complex that then translocates
into the nucleus so we believe that
possibly what's happening in that BMP
can block tgf-beta because it is
competing for smart spore and so it
takes more of this mad for and therefore
it's it can then go on to activate the
genes in the nucleus and upregulate IDs
two and three or promote the the up
regulation of these genes so potentially
that could be what's happening in the
blocking effect of BMP seven could be
competition for smart for and in
addition to maintaining those levels of
ie two and three to protect the cells
from EMT
okay so to summarize everything which
was quoted quite a lot on all the growth
factors signaling pathways firstly the
important thing here is that we're
really looking at anterior sub capsular
cataract and posterior capsular
opacification following cataract surgery
and they're both really important forms
of fibrotic cataract and that's what
scarring respond so talking about where
we're just clouds or lens and we get
that loss of transparency so the aim of
our research really is trying to prevent
these diseases from happening so we can
promote lens transparency and protect
the lens so that it can do its job in
focusing light onto the retina and
tgf-beta is a really potent inducer of
these fibrotic forms of cataract and
that activates a complex network of
signaling pathways as you saw today it
activates the canonical smads signaling
pathway and it also activates the non
canonical EGFR signaling pathway and up
as well and they all seem to form this
crosstalk which is quite complex and
it's still something we need to tease
out and in addition to all these
pathways in fact there's actually many
other pathways that are also activated
by tgf-beta and so we're looking into
all these other pathways to see if
there's any connections there what I've
shown also today is that there's
different growth factors that float
around in the aqueous humor of the eye
and they can impact on tgf-beta
differently so in in one instance you've
got a growth factor like EGF so I can
alternate tgf-beta and then we've got
BMP that can block tgf-beta so really as
much as it's really interesting to study
the effects of tgf-beta alone we have to
be mindful that in the actual real life
situation there's lots of different
growth factors and as I mentioned
there's actually even more than those
three so if you put all of those in the
mix what actually happens and that's
something that our lab is working to
understand further is that what actually
happens
inside the i2 impact on the activity and
the fibrotic activity of tgf-beta but
what I what I really want to highlight
is that if we block EGFR cycling or if
we promote BMP signaling then we can
really target cataracts and we can
potentially block the form of fibrotic
cataracts which is really exciting and
they can be quite novel strategies to
cure cataract and finally I would like
to acknowledge the members of my lab in
particular my supervisor professor Frank
Lubbock you and also Donner entering
from the Bosch Institute at the
University of Sydney for helping me
especially with the PCR and lastly um if
you'd like to reach out to me I'm more
than happy to talk more about my
research I'm on Twitter
also you can follow me and I DS issue
and also on Instagram you can visit my
website or you can email me so I'm more
than happy to hear from you or any of
your thoughts or my research or just
anything in general about social media
I'm always happy to hear that and
finally I'd be more than happy to hear
any questions so please feel free to ask
any questions now
Thank You jay-z for that
presentation now just a quick reminder
to our audience on how to submit
questions simply type them into the ask
a question box and click on the send
button we will answer as many questions
as we have time for ok Daisy your first
question could the expression of er K 1
a or K 2 in the I be a signal for NCI
mild cognitive impairments as these
markers are well documented in MCI or
vice-versa
alright thanks so much for that question
I have actually never really thought
about mild cognitive impairment but
that's a really interesting link because
mild cognitive impairment is actually
more prevalent in the older population
as is cataract and so they could
definitely be a link there in addition
to that I know that oxidative stress
plays a big role in the type of cataract
that we're looking at in fact work in
our laboratory has shown that reactive
oxygen species does get increased in our
type of cataract so there could
definitely be a link looking at a 1 & 2
& work in our lab has shown that if you
block up then you can block the cataract
we haven't really tied the links between
whether or not there are any brain
abnormalities but that could be a really
novel way of looking at looking at sort
of brain functions by using the eye as
as a sort of more easy to like readily
accessible means of looking at brain
functions so I'd be really curious to
see you know if there's any sort of
research out there and if someone could
really do that experiment I'm very
curious to see that so thanks for that
question
Thank You Daisy how do you avoid in true
introducing inspections into the
patroness petri dish that's a super
important question and what we do is in
our cell culture media we've got
antibiotics so we've got penicillin
streptomycin and we've also got
amphotericin B so these things really do
help to reduce any sort of contamination
in addition to that we just try our best
to be as Derald possible we do our
experiments in the hood and also make
sure that we UV the hood and a UV the
room as well before and after our
experiments and we 70% ethanol
everything as well so those are like
some of the things we do
nowadays you have you use human le C's
in your work
yes I have actually um so some of the
newer work in my research is using so
when as I showed in the presentation the
surgeon when they do that when they
perform the cataract surgery they
actually have to remove all that
material that is that it has undergone
that cataract exchange so when they
remove it they actually discard that
material now those cells that are part
of some that cataracts can actually be
used for experiments so having yes
having like collaborated with a cataract
surgery I was able to collect some of
these cells and actually culture them
and they perform up they responded in a
very similar way to be rat lenses so
that was really cool and it's a really
great way to use material that would
typically have born in the bin to
actually see if we can translate some of
our animal work to the human situation
this system applicable to lenses of all
species
that's a great question I've actually
done lens epithelial explains on mice
lenses and that's actually a really
great way to study study transgenic
mouse models and kind of see if these
lenses perform in the same way because
it's really yeah often we don't really
do sort of gene manipulation on rats and
it's usually my so that's definitely a
really great way of testing if we
overexpress certain genes or knock out
certain genes in mice will be lens
epithelial cell behaves the same way
when we add different growth factors so
I have done this successfully on mice
although they are super super tiny
compared to rat eyeballs so it just
requires a little bit more practice
before you do it but it is possible and
I've read in the literature people have
used big lenses as well and big lenses
are actually a lot larger so they're
probably a lot easier to use and so
that's that's another very very great
model to use and other people have used
embryonic check closes and of course the
human lens epithelial cells you can get
from doughnut lenses and also the
discarded material after cataract
surgery so those are the ones I've read
in the literature but it's definitely
possible
Thank You Daisy now given a link between
oxidative stress and cataract formation
have you looked at the regulatory effect
of oxidative stress induced PTMs on
tgf-b and EGFR regulated pathways
okay um pts could it could the the
possibly off that question just clarify
what they mean by pts other than guy and
I forgot right Brian thank you for your
question if you could elaborate on what
PTMs are and submit your question again
we'll be able to answer that after the
next few questions thanks okay we'll go
to your next question Daisy what are
some ways that the drug can be delivered
to the eye to stop cataract formation
that's that's a good question so the way
I envision this treatment to be
administered to humans is probably
during the time of cataract surgery so
this is this is when we're talking about
the secondary types of cataract so I I
believe like at the time the surgery is
be really ideal for the intraocular lens
so that's that implant that's put in the
in place of the removed cataract that
lens can be loaded up with a drug that
slowly releases and there's actually
some papers in the literature on people
who are trying to develop such an
intraocular lens implant that slowly
releases drugs and I think that would be
a really novel way to incorporate these
inhibitors to block that secondary
cataracts and for me the other really
interesting ways would be would be
looking at an eye drop formulation and
the only issue with that is how how can
cross the layers of the eye to actually
reach the lens another way is to have an
injection into the aqueous here and
that's another way and because the
surgeon during the times cataract
surgery is already going to be injecting
antibiotics and anti-inflammatory agents
it makes sense to also inject something
that will stop that fibrotic effect from
forming so those are the ways I see that
this these inhibitors could be
incorporated in the real world
Thank You jay-z now let's go back to
that previous question given the link
between oxidative stress and cataract
formation have you looked at the
regulatory effect of oxidative stress
induced post translational modifications
PTMs on tgf-b and EGFR regulated
pathways okay great thanks thanks for
clarifying that Brian I haven't actually
looked at that but work in our
laboratory by another PhD student has
looked at oxidative stress not post
translational modifications per se and
not on EGFR so purely on reactive
oxidative
oxygen species and tgf-beta and
specifically he looked at the role of
noxus and they're really interesting
sort of players in reactive oxygen
species where they they can actually
produce reactive oxygen species and he
found that certain noxes are upregulated
during during the addition of tgf-beta
and if you block NOx for then you can
block our tgf-beta induce DMT which was
really interesting and he's he's looking
into that server looking at
mitochondrial stress and things like
that but that's definitely an area that
is developing and it's a really
interesting area and I I'm so curious to
see how EGFR listed into that and it's
not an area we've looked at but I would
be really curious about that
the Lacs are present in a low-oxygen
micro environment how do you factor that
into your findings
that's a really interesting question the
learns episode I haven't really
considered oxygen availability or
content in in my studies we pretty much
just used standard cell culture settings
in the incubator I guess so I haven't
quite thought about that but I know that
hypoxia it plays a big role in lens
epithelial cells oxidant stress so I'll
be really curious to see whether or not
any hypoxia up regulated genes would be
involved in tgf-beta induced EMT we
haven't actually looked at that but
that's a really interesting next step to
look into Thanks
Thank You Daisy and we are almost out of
time so we're going to wrap with this
final question and a reminder to our
audience that any questions we do not
have time for today and those submitted
during our on-demand period will be
addressed via the contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration
ok GZ with mouse lens epithelial X plans
how much proteins RNA and DNA do
typically recover from one pair of
mouseland's epithelial X plants that's a
very good question it's like a tiny tiny
amount sadly because the mouse eyeballs
are tiny and obviously we're taking the
lens epithelial cells just a monolayer
of cells from these mice I haven't
really worked that much with mouseland's
epithelia excellent
I've only kind of done a flat mount with
them and stain them for
immunofluorescence which is a little bit
easy like easier to do but I have some
lab mates who have looked at collecting
them and I would say that they typically
need like five five pairs of lenses in
order to get like a substantial amount
of RNA and DNA and protein so in order
to you know run the PCRs and western
blots i couldn't tell you exactly the
concentration that they get but they're
getting proteins being expressed like
the western blots actually showing days
with about 5x plants per per treatment
group so yeah it's definitely harder
with these primary x plants but it's
feasible so yeah I definitely yeah it's
a great system to use if you're wanting
you to have the cells on their native
basement membrane so that's like that's
probably the biggest advantage with
these exploits but as I said yet the
protein and RNA that you can actually
extract from each one is quite limited
for the rats we can get away with about
three but typically I like to have
five rat eyes treatment group for one
experiment just to get as much about
protein RNA per group thanks Thank You
Daisy and thank you to our audience for
joining us and for their interesting
questions these if you have any final
comments for our audience I just want to
say a huge thank you to lab roots and
keep code for giving me this amazing
opportunity to share my research with
you all I am so thankful to all the
attendees but actually tuning in and
listening and you all are so many really
insightful and amazing questions and
have given me a lot of food food support
in terms of where I can take my research
next so thank you so much for those
thank you again Daisy I would also like
to thank lab route and our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
laberd's will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event you will now be directed to
our next upcoming webinar we encourage
you to register and we hope to see you
there goodbye
okay what